thank you it's nice to be here I'm gonna
try to review in in 40 minutes 15 years
of history in the rapidly changing in
the exchange marketplace with an
emphasis on on the game theoretic
aspects at a high level that is how the
incentives have changed over time how
that has caused people to behave
differently how that has caused us to
use different algorithms to try to
organize exchanges than we did when we
began many of you will already be
familiar with some of this so so I'm
gonna move quickly san-tomás here who is
your more expert than I on many of the
algorithmic aspects oh so again I'm
gonna I'm gonna move in a high level
today
so the first exchange in the u.s. took
place in New England in 2000 economists
only got involved economists and
computer scientists only got involved
later than that the question was how to
make the market thick some of the very
first kidney exchanges and I'll tell you
more about those if this is the first
day you're hearing the word kidney
exchange some of the first kidney
exchanges were actually arranged by the
patient don't repairs themselves meeting
in dialysis waiting rooms so that's not
the way to organize a market so the
question was how to how to organize it
to have a large-scale thicker
marketplace for kidney exchanges when we
started talking to our surgical
colleagues they said to us that only
small scale exchanges could be conducted
and that changed the algorithms that
that led to the initial startups of the
multi Hospital kidney exchanges but
since then we've been able to do larger
exchanges and incorporate chains and as
kidney exchange has become a standard
form of transplantation in the United
States the the game has changed the
players have changed instead of dealing
with just surgeons and patients and
donors we're now dealing with directors
of transplant centers and directors of
transplant centers have different
strategy sets turns out one of the
things they can do is withhold they're
easy to match pairs that means that the
multi Hospital kidney exchanges are
dealing with harder to match pairs and
that changes the the algorithms and the
the optimal kinds of exchanges that that
we're starting to see so that's the
story I want to tell you and if there's
time I'll tell you a little bit about
where we're going now
one of the things I really will try to
get into time I'll skip things if I
don't get there is I do want to let you
know that market design isn't just about
analytics that there are other things
that go on in in implementing market so
I'll tell you about that too so lots of
collaborators in this work and lots of
different kinds of journals so the the
papers on this page all have the
journals all have economics in their
name and some of the some of the
breakpoints I'll tell you about have to
do with the way incentives changed but
there's also medical collaborators and
the the journals on this page all have
medicine or transplantation in their
name so so market design is an outward
facing part of economics and computer
science if we want people to if you want
to help people to do the things they're
trying to do we have to talk to them in
in in their fora not just talk to
ourselves if I get a chance and I'm
gonna definitely try to get a chance to
to talk to you about some of the non
analytic elements of design in some very
recent work and possibly I'll get to
talk about where we might be going so to
start with an algorithm that that looked
initially like it might help us organize
kidney exchange let me go back to a 1974
paper by Shapley and scarf it came out
in volume 1 number 1 of the Journal of
mathematical analysis I like to say that
because sometimes people think that
theory and application are very distant
from each other but but in fact this was
quite an abstract model and what they
said was they said let's consider a
model where you have n agents each of
whom has an indivisible good and no
money is available to facilitate trade
how could they trade among themselves
and of course those of you who live in
California know that this isn't actually
a model of houses we use money for house
but as will quickly become apparent to
you and it slowly became apparent to me
this might start to be a model for
kidney exchange
what they said they introduced a an
algorithm called top trading cycles that
had been proposed to them by David gale
they said
supposing everyone has a house here's an
algorithm that that we could use to
trade houses among ourselves once we
know our preferences for houses pick
someone in the room at random well pick
someone in the room and ask them point
to the house you like best and they
point to a house and to the person who
owns the house and you say to the person
being pointed to point to the house you
like best because there are only a
finite number of houses someone will
eventually point to a house that has
already been pointed to it might be
someone points to his own house it might
be that I point you to Chris and she
points back to me it might be that I
point to Chris and she points to Eva and
Eva points back to Chris so so I don't
have to be in the cycle that forms but
eventually a cycle will form what the
algorithm says is when that top trading
cycle forms have everyone take the house
that they're pointing to and leave the
market so those people all got their
first choice houses and they go and then
the people remaining we say point to the
house you like best among those that
remain at every stage at least one house
has to leave the market so on a finite
number of steps there's an allocation
and what Shapley and scarf observed is
that that allocation is in the core of
the game that is there's no group of
people who could have arranged a trade
that they would have preferred among
themselves and the way you can see that
is supposing you were trying to recruit
a coalition of people who could trade
among themselves and get something they
liked better than they were assigned at
top trading cycles well as you started
to recruit this coalition you'd notice
you couldn't recruit anyone who was in
that first cycle because they all got
their very first choice house they can't
be made better off so to recruit to make
people better off who left in the second
cycle you would have to get someone you
would have to get one of the houses that
left in the first cycle because everyone
who left in the second cycle got their
very favorite house among those that
would that remained but we already saw
that you can't recruit the people in the
first cycle and so you can't build a
cycle you can't build a trading group
that could do better among themselves so
so the outcome is in the core it
wouldn't cause smaller groups of traders
to defect and arrange their own trade
and indeed when the preference is
our strict there's a unique allocation
in the course so some of the things
about the algorithm that I didn't say to
you like what's the exact order in which
we formed cycles turn out not to be
important if we started with a different
person and said point to the house you
like best we might have got an initial
different initial cycle but we wouldn't
have gotten a different allocation of
houses to people and that's because
cycles don't intersect with each other
there aren't a lot of choices in cycles
the cycles form themselves now if you
wanted to use an algorithm like this to
form a centralized Clearinghouse that
would produce outcomes that that people
couldn't do better on their own to get
those outcomes those core outcomes
depend on the Preferences so you would
have to have a way of eliciting the
preferences the preferences are always
going to be well are here going to be
private information there'll be some
aspects of the Preferences that are
private information and it turns out
it's a it's safe for people to tell you
their preferences if you're going to use
those preferences in a top trading cycle
algorithm and I won't prove that for you
here but but the the issue is here's mr.
I we've asked him to point to his first
choice house and he's done so but we can
see that that isn't going to help him
right he's pointing to a cycle that
doesn't include him so when we run the
top trading cycles algorithm those
cycles are gonna disappear and he's
going to be left pointing without having
gotten the house that he pointed to and
so the question is was it safe for him
to tell us that that was his first
choice or could he have done better by
pointing somewhere else
for instance if he had pointed here he
could have gotten this house he would
have formed a cycle a 3-way cycle with
these guys if he had pointed here he
would have gotten this house if he had
pointed here he would have gotten his
house those were his opportunity set and
what you can see is his opportunity said
is never going to shrink the people who
he could have pointed to and formed a
cycle will remain until he leaves
because they are all pointing directly
or indirectly to him so they will never
be part of any cycle until he is and
therefore it is safe for him to tell us
his first choice although he didn't get
his first choice now that everyone is
pointing in the air everyone's gonna
have to point to their first choice
among those remaining and this guy might
point here or here or here for instance
and that will add these guys to - mr
i--'s opportunity set so this
opportunity set will only grow and it's
a dominant strategy for him to state his
true preferences and so the next thing
that came along before any of us were
thinking about kidneys was till I blue
code the Robo and typhoon summers
thought about extending this housing
model to it to a different kind of
housing they said how about dormitories
and the thing about dormitories in
colleges is some rooms are occupied some
rooms have just been vacated by
graduating seniors and are unoccupied
and there are freshmen who have just
arrived on campus who need rooms but
don't have any and so there's going to
be an analogy in the in the kidney
transplant world to patients who have
willing donors and are looking to trade
a kidney because their donors are
incompatible deceased donors who offer a
kidney but have no recipient in mind and
patients on the waiting list for
deceased donation who need a kidney and
have no no donor in mind and indeed to
tell you about transplantation a little
bit there are a lot of diseases for
which transplantation is the best
treatment but but kidney disease is
special because first there's dialysis
so you can stay alive for a while with
failed kidneys and second healthy people
have two kidneys and therefore it's
possible that you could give a kidney to
someone you loved and save their life
but there aren't enough kidneys more
than a hundred thousand people are
waiting this morning for on the deceased
donor waiting list and in recent years
we do about 11,000 deceased donor
transplants a year so that's not nearly
enough the waiting list is long you can
die while on the waiting list and
thousands of people die each year but
deceased and and deceased donation
incidentally if you have a California
driver's license when you went to
register for it they they asked you did
you want to be on the deceased donor
list and if you said yes at that time
there's a little dot on your driver's
license and if you want to say yes now
you can point your browser to to
something like donate life gov
California and find the registration
list there but but they were also living
donors and in the u.s. we now do
more than half as many roughly living
donations as deceased donations so
11,000 living donation somewhat more
than 5,500 deceased donation living
donations that means there are more
living donors than there are deceased
donors deceased donors donate two
kidneys living donors only donate one
kidney because if you are as healthy as
you as I hope you are you can donate a
kidney and and save someone's life but
sometimes you're healthy enough to
donate a kidney but you can't give it to
the person you love because kidneys have
to fit they have to be matched medically
to recipient and this is where exchange
comes in this is where algorithms like
Shapley's and scarfs stop trading cycles
might make sense because all of a sudden
there are pairs who have a kidney
you know donor one would like to give a
kidney to a recipient one but can't so
here they are they have a kidney here's
another pair in the same situation and
what you see is the blood type a kidney
could go to the blood type a patient and
the blood type B kidney could go to the
blood type B patient and we get two
transplants that we wouldn't otherwise
get so exchange is possible and this is
a simple trading cycle of the sort that
that we started to think about in more
generality a moment ago now when we
started as I said the players were the
patients and the donors and their
surgeons and it looked like the it
looked to us at the time and it was
indeed for for a few years ten years ago
it looked to us like the patients and
donors we were going to see we're going
to be pretty much randomly sampled from
the general population of patients and
donors okay that has changed over time
and I'll tell you about that but if it
were the case that patients and donors
were being randomly sampled then then
then it'll show you some results that
suggest that we should be able to do
kidney exchange just with small
exchanges that is the cycles that we
find in top trading cycles wouldn't have
to be very long they might many many of
them might be short like this but that
turns out not to be the case so it
hasn't turned out to be the case so our
original proposal before we understood
any of this before we had
and really talked to our surgical
colleagues was to do top trading cycles
for kidneys okay and I won't talk about
that too much except to say that we had
an ambitious proposal that involved both
the living the the incompatible patient
donor pairs and the deceased donor pool
there are big regulatory differences
between how deceased donors and living
donors are handled in the United States
and so we're we're still working on the
politics associated with integrating the
deceased donor pool into into kidney
exchange so let me not say too much more
about that except that you can prove
nice theorems about about all the
transplants you could do with top
trading cycles but it turns out there
are logistical problems to doing large
cycles so here's a picture that is in
Cincinnati Ohio and around 2006 and I'm
the man in the yellow gown keeping my
hands out of the way and in the bucket
there is a kidney and behind me not in
this picture on the right but behind me
in the picture on the left just steps
away is another operating room where the
nephrectomy that takes that kidney has
just been performed and that kidney is
going into this guy in Cincinnati Ohio
and at the same time in Toledo Ohio the
donor who loves this guy and the patient
who is loved by the lady who donated
this kidney are undergoing the same pair
of surgeries in Toledo Ohio and when I
say at the same time I mean literally at
the same time because the American law
that prevents you from buying a kidney
makes it a felony to buy a kidney for
transplantation actually says you can't
give valuable consideration for for an
organ for transplant what that means is
you can't write a contract on a kidney
so in particular you can't write a
contract that says we'll give you a
kidney today and you give us a kidney
tomorrow so to make sure that no gaps
happen in this cycle the surgeons get on
their phones from the operating room
they they anesthetize the patients they
they performed in the frec t'me and in
this case the donors had traveled I'm
sorry they get on there
they anesthetize the patients they make
the initial incisions then they get on
their phones and they say we're ready in
Cincinnati
are you ready in Toledo and the surgeons
are dropped here this is Steve Woodall
in Cincinnati and on the other end is
Mike Reiss in Toledo and when Mike
answers his phone and says we're ready
to go here
then the nephrectomy takes place and the
transplants go on and what that means
luzhin I'm telling you this this bit of
detail what that means is to do this
simple exchange between two pairs
requires four simultaneous operating
rooms and four simultaneous surgical
teams so there's some logistics in just
getting a two-way exchange going and you
could imagine that if you wanted to do a
three-way exchange you need six
operating rooms if you wanted to do a
10-way exchange you'd need 20 operating
rooms and 20 surgical teams and so very
early on when we started talking to our
surgical colleagues this is in early
2000 they said you know this is hard
enough if you want to help us organize
kidney exchange help us organize kidney
exchange between two pairs so if you can
only do two pairs at a time you're not
going to get as many transplants as you
might with assemblies of bigger cycles
and chains but but you can't tap into
some very old very elegant graph theory
that many of you will know about in
particular if we're only gonna do
two-way exchanges we can model the
possible exchanges as an undirected
graph in which the vertices are the
patient donor pairs and two nodes two
vertices are connected to each other if
they have the double coincidence of
wants if if they can each use the kidney
that the other one has okay and in that
case when we when we have that kind of
set of vertices and edges a matching is
just going to be a collection of edges
that touches each vertex only once each
pair will only engage in one exchange
and the nice property that the set of
matchable vertices has is that it's a
mate right so that all the all the
maximal Cardinal cardinality matching x'
are the same size and you can use greedy
algorithms so in particular if you have
high priority patients you can have an
algorithm that says let's take our
highest priority patient and see if
there's any
change that that he can benefit from and
if so we put him in the group that will
be matched then we look at our second
highest priority patient this is
actually very similar to the way that
for many organs and deceased donor
organs are allocated so this was a
familiar kind of process and it allows
you to say that all that not to worry
about the the size of the maximal
matching greedy algorithms work and it's
a dominant strategy for all the pairs to
reveal the information that goes into
that compatibility graph okay and in
those days among the information that
had to be revealed were results of blood
tests today we do many of the blood
tests centrally and in some of the big
kidney exchanges but still not in others
but also you can see that no matter how
the technology changes for gathering the
information in the compatibility graph
some information will always remain
private
supposing God forbid you go to the
doctor and find out you're gonna need a
kidney transplant in the future so you
go home to Thanksgiving and you say to
your family bad news I'm gonna need a
kidney transplant but your family loves
you so your brother and your sister and
your cousin and your aunt all say I'd be
willing to give you a kidney and they're
all tested and they're all incompatible
but you now have a bunch of potential
donors and they could they could go into
the graph with you giving you lots of
edges okay now you could easy but that
would be good for you and it would be
good for the whole system like denser
graph will allow more matchings so but
you could imagine that we could do
something silly like saying you know
people who have only a single donor
should have higher priority than people
who have multiple donors because people
who have multiple donors are already
advantaged in so many ways and if we did
that but in that case you would say -
you're at over the Thanksgiving table
you would say to your mother and your
brother and their cousin and your aunt
you would say you know my surgeon tells
me that it's not wise to come with many
donors I should come with only one donor
and then we wouldn't see all the
possibilities of exchange so so if we so
so a big part of market design is
choosing algorithms choosing the
priorities in this case in ways that
make it incentive compatible
for people to give us the information
that we depend on them to give us that
we need to make efficient matchings okay
so without anything to do about kidneys
if you have a maximal matching in a in
an undirected graph you can decompose it
into under demanded and over demanded
and perfectly matched pairs and the
under demanded pairs are the pairs that
will get matched at some maximal
matchings but not at others and the over
demanded pairs are their neighbors who
get matched at every maximal matching so
now I'd like to populate this graph for
you with actual kidney stories and tell
you who's who's in it this this has
nothing to do with kidneys this is a
graph theory theorem and to do that
we'll have to I'll talk about it not
just in two-way matching I'll have to
tell you a little bit about
compatibility
basically there are two things going on
about whether you can take my kidney
the first is blood type there are two
blood components called a and B and your
blood type is which of them you have so
if you have just a your blood type a if
your both your blood type a B and if you
have none of them in English we say you
have blood type O in many languages they
say blood type zero which indicates that
you don't have any of the blood
components and the rule is you can't
take you can't easily take a kidney from
someone who has a blood component that
you don't have okay so oh patients can
only take from donors but owed owners
can give to everyone now mostly with
some significant important exceptions
like Methodist Hospital in San Antonio
most kidney exchanges only enroll in
compatible patient donor pairs if you
show up with your sister who wants to
give you a kidney and she can then
without further ado most transplant
centers will say to you that's great how
about we all meet 5:30 Tuesday morning
and in in the operating room and you'll
get your sister's kidney that's not
necessarily the the best thing for them
to do for you or for for the world but
that's the story so if blood type
compatibility were the only issue we
would never see any blood type o donors
because blood type o donors are always
blood type
paddle with the people they want to give
a kidney to but there's another kind of
incompatibility that has to do with your
immune system and the sicker you've been
the more blood transfusions you've got
if you've had a kidney that you've
rejected in the past the more antibodies
you have to human proteins those live on
a when chromosome six and if you have
antibodies to a lot of proteins then you
become hard to match and we talked about
your percent of reactive antibodies if
you have a high number that's bad for
you if your number is eighty we start to
call you highly sensitized or we're used
to now now the highly sensitized numbers
are much higher that means that you
can't take 80% of the kidneys that are
blood type compatible and so the reason
we get ODE owners in kidney exchange
even among incompatible patient donor
pairs is that many many patients are are
highly sensitized okay
so we're gonna talk about compatibility
graphs now that are directed so there's
a pair and arrow goes from one pair to
another if the if the kidney can go from
the donor in that pair to the patient in
the next and one way to imagine what
kidney exchange would have looked like
if we were getting a random selection of
patients is to look at random graphs of
a nerd or any sort and say let's let the
market gets large and the graph get
dense because even if people are pretty
highly sensitized which means they can
only take a small percentage of the
kidneys that that might look like they
would otherwise be compatible if there
are enough patients and donors in the
pool then there'll be enough kidneys for
everyone being able to take one percent
of a large number of kidneys still gives
you a lot of kidneys and so in order for
any kind of graph we're gonna let the
number of nodes grow and there'll be
some probability P that the two nodes
are connected when we specialize this
two kidneys the nodes will consist of
patient donor pairs that will have two
blood types associated with them one for
the patient and one for the donor so
we'll have to be a little careful in how
we bring
kind of tools into the into the result
but what you but when you look at the
giant connected components that result
in the air - araignee world what you see
is I can now fulfill the promise I made
a moment ago when I showed you the guy
at Men's decomposition I can show you in
this nice world which would be the over
demanded on the under demanded pairs and
the over demanded pairs are going to be
patient donor pairs with a patient for
instance has blood type a and the donor
has blood type O this is a very
desirable donor he can give to everyone
the patient is not demanding such a
desirable kidney he can take an a kidney
as well as an O kidney so this whole
shaded area these pairs are going to be
used up in a large enough market in any
other matching at any maximal matching
whereas the kind of pairs will be left
over or the old patients who are
offering an a kidney right an O patient
is hard to match he needs an O kidney
and O kidneys are going to be in short
supply because they're in high demand
and because they're often compatible
with with their own donors and he's only
offering an a kidney so loosely speaking
when we when we match in the giant
connected set we'll we'll be able to
take good care of all of these pairs but
we'll always have pairs of this sort
left over in particular o patients will
will be an excess supply a B donors will
be hard to give away right because they
can only give to a B patients so we'd
also like to talk about chains so chains
we have actually the data aren't so
clear but but we've had about 1,500
clear non directed donors in the United
States so far in a non directed donor is
the donor who doesn't have a particular
patient in mind wants to give a kidney
about 1/3 of the non directed donors in
the United States come from faith-based
organizations from religious
organizations and so in addition to
talking about you know two-way exchanges
and 3-way exchanges we might also talk
about a chain which could possibly end
on a patient who's on the waiting list
for a deceased donor that is it could
start with a donor who doesn't have a
particular patient in mind and it could
end with a patient who who doesn't have
a particular donor dedicated to them
what we used to do when non directed
donors showed up you go through lots of
medical screens and psychological
screens and we used to be particularly
tough on non directed donors but when
you pass through all those screens you
could you were invited to give to
someone on the waiting list but once the
kidney exchange marketplace became thick
and we had databases of patient donor
pairs you could offer non directed
donors or more enticing possibility
which is you could spark a chain of
transplants you could give to a
recipient who's who was waiting for
exchange and who has an incompatible
donor who will give to a different
recipient who's incompatible donor will
give to someone on the waiting list so
that instead of facilitating one
transplant y'all go facilitate three and
when you look at a picture like that it
has this is a picture from from a such a
chain that that was organized in 2006 it
has six people in the picture and one
question is only six and one answer is
logistics in 2006 well we could handle
and it's still close to what we can
handle these three transplants and three
nephrectomies at the same time so when
you do all these simultaneously you need
to you need to mobilize six surgical
teams and and six operating rooms at the
same time and we were doing this in the
New England program for kidney exchange
which is in New England it has there are
14 transplant centers
New England and to opiates to organ
procurement organizations well but
another reason why why there might only
be six people in the picture is that
after we've done a maximal exchange in
this ideal world this is going to turn
out not to be the actual kidney exchange
world but but would bear with me all of
these guys are gone all the over
demanded pairs have been exhausted so we
only have these guys so supposing our
non-directed donor is blood type o the
blood type o donor could give to this
blood type o patient who has a blood
type a donor who could give this to this
blood type a patient who is a blood type
a B donor now there are no more a B
patients up here they're all in the over
demanded said it's easy to match them
they were easy to match pairs but
there's a hundred thousand people on the
waiting list four percent of Americans
have blood type a B so there's always
plenty of AV patients here so we could
do this three transplant six person
change so that's another reason why they
might be only six people maybe that's
all you can get it turns out that's not
all you can get and the reason is as the
hospitals have become the players the
game has changed right it used to be
that kidney exchange was was very
unusual and you had to deal with the
kidney exchange networks but knew how to
do it but now every big transplant
center in the United States has done
some kidney exchange and the the people
we're now dealing with our directors of
transplant centers who have different
strategy sets than surgeons and patients
and donors because directors of
transplant centers don't see individual
patients and donors they see sets of
patients and donors and so they can
decide which subset of the patients and
donors they see to show to the multi
hospital kidney exchange and there are
good reasons that that we haven't yet
been able to overcome in the kidney
exchange algorithms that they might
hesitate to show us they're easy to
match pairs there are also logistical
reasons but for example think of this
little compatibility graph where all the
guys with named a a 1 a 2 a 3 they come
from transplant center a so you're the
director of transplant center a and you
look at this graph and you say look at
that I can get 3 of my patients
transplanted by having them exchange
with each other
at my hospital alternatively I could
show them to one of the big kidney
exchanges okay to national kidney
registry to the Alliance prepared
donation to you knows and they'll see
some compatibility graph and maybe
they'll look at this compatibility graph
and they'll say you know we can get six
transplants we can do these two
three-way exchanges but of course
hospital a will only get two of those
transplants one of its patients will be
left out so right now we think we know
how to how to fix this problem but it
would involve prioritizing patients
partly in terms of which hospitals they
come from which has not been a
politically feasible thing to do yet so
so for various reasons among them having
to do with direct incentive reasons
hospital sometimes withhold they're easy
to match pairs and what that means is
when we look at the at the sensitivity
of the patients I showed you in the
general patient population only 10% of
the patients have PRA or immuno
sensitivities higher than 85 percent or
than 80 percent we're seeing a big mode
of very very highly sensitized patients
and when I blow that up they are really
highly sensitized that you know a lot of
these guys have a hundred percent PRA
that means when we enter them into the
system at the moment we enter them into
the system there are no kidneys that
they could take even as a one-way
there's no arrow going into them into
their node okay so they're gonna be very
hard to match and here's a here's a
little bit of data from such a
compatibility graph remember each node
is a patient donor payer or a patient
and her donors an arrow goes from one
node to another only if the kidney can
go from the donor in the first pair to
the patient in the second pair and
everybody in this picture just for
expository purposes everybody has blood
type a right all the patients and all
the donors have blood type a so the
sparsity comes entirely from the fact
that these patients are very highly
sensitized it's only eight pairs that
have a lot of incoming arrows and all
the rest have have very few and what
that means is you can't do a lot of
short cycles a lot of two-way exchanges
we
these highly sensitized patients and
this is why you're going to need chains
and to model the graph that you're
getting the random graph you it's not
going to be densely connected but
they'll be there'll be some low
sensitized patient donor pairs who are
densely connected but the best use of
them will be to form chains in the
highly sensitized group
supposing where each of us is a patient
donor parent and we're all as patients
were all very highly sensitized that
means the chance that I can give one of
you a kidney is very small but if the
room is big enough the chance that I can
give someone a kidney isn't so small now
if I'm highly sensitized the chance you
can give a kidney back is very very
small but if the room is big enough the
chance you can give a kidney to someone
else isn't so small so we could start
making a change and that chain would go
among the highly sensitized patients
until you couldn't get any further and
then you could bounce it back up to the
to the easy to match pairs because
they're easy to match they can take
kidneys and then you could continue okay
and it turns out that rather than saying
that all the the exchanges could be done
in small cycles what it says here is if
you increase by one that's the size of a
cycle you're allowing from 2 to 3 from 3
to 4 you can get a linear number of
extra transplants and similarly if you
bring in a non directed donor now you
don't have to the cycle doesn't have to
close you're gonna get a linear number
of extra transplant so chains are going
to be pretty important and we have to
figure out how to do chains because if
we can only do six people at a time and
we'll do six people because we have to
do all the surgeries simultaneously we
won't be able to do it so we figured out
that we could do non simultaneous chains
let me not tell you about that too much
but the first chain that was that Apple
doesn't like like mice my some of my
slides the first chain was published in
a in a paper in the New England Journal
of Medicine in which my crease was the
first author and they were economists
and computer scientists Thomas was one
of them when it was published it had 20
people in the picture ok the last lady
on the chain was was blood type a B
which we
try not to do that anymore if the chain
ended today this way we would ask her to
donate to someone on the deceased donor
list so it took three years to find a
suitable match for her because a B
patients who are in the kidney exchange
pool tend to be very very highly
sensitized otherwise they could have
taken their donors kidney but but after
three years another 12 people were added
to this picture and she was Elena
McKinney was the lady who waited three
years we don't we don't ask anyone to do
that anymore
okay so chains are important because
there are so many highly sensitized
patients that can only be reached
through change they can't be reached
through through short cycles and some of
the chains have gotten very long when
this one went through in in 2011 and 12
it was at that time the longest chain
there are there are 60 people in the
picture
okay 30 transplants and 30 nephrectomies
it's no longer the longest one it's
still an unusually long one the average
chain at the nkr and the APD is about
five people so many chains are shorter
sometimes donors have deadlines and have
to go home quickly things like that but
but the average chain length is five
people so so we get a lot of transplants
from non-directed donors some
computational notes finding two-way
exchanges is computationally easy you
know when you see that nice structure in
the Goliath's decomposition you know
that Edmonds algorithm is going to be a
fast one
finding maximal to weigh in three-way
exchanges is computationally complex
finding pop Trading cycles is easy you
know exchanges of any size but
restricting them is tough and when you
have lots of chains give SEAPLEX memory
problems right I mean you can really
generate a lot of constraints because
chains are intersecting an eight-person
chain is a subset of a nine-person chain
and it could also be there could be
seven-person chains instead of
eight-person chains and chains can
branch so they can really be a lot of
chains the the integers programs that we
use to solve these things are therefore
difficult to deal with Thompson's
colleagues look at column generating
methods
my colleagues and I have looked at row
generating methods Apple Computer
doesn't like my typefaces I thought but
but these are np-complete problems that
our however solvable in practice not
that they aren't difficult instances so
it's not one of these cases like the
simplex method where you never run into
a hard problem we run into hard problems
but so far they seem to be solvable so
there are certainly open questions about
that let me close up by telling you
about operational changes right so so
far I've been telling you
you know the game changed the algorithm
that the behavior change so the kind of
exchange is changed we'vewe've we went
from two-way exchanges to two two and
three-way exchanges to two and three
exchanges and short chains and now we're
mostly optimizing over two and three-way
exchanges and sometimes very long
non-simultaneous chains but that's not
the only thing that's going on it turns
out when we started to produce these
optimal solutions we were getting very
few transplants and a lot of what
happened was what what I mean we're
getting few transplants we'd we'd
propose a matching you know so a
three-way exchange a two-way exchange
two small chains something like that
that's a matching each part of that
matching is what I'll call an offer that
is we are saying to some Hospital we
have a kidney that could might work for
your patient do you want it only 15% in
2007 only 15% of those offers resulted
in transplant now they weren't all being
rejected if part of our optimal exchange
is a three-way three-way exchange and if
the surgeon for the patient in pair 3
rejects this kidney then then all of
these offers fail we can't we can't do
the exchange so the question was what
was going on with that 15% rejection
rate some of it was mechanical was the
blood tests weren't all of the same
high-quality at all the hospital so we
centralized the blood testing now I'm
speaking about the Alliance for paired
donation but a lot of it had to do with
elements of surgeons preferences for
kidneys that are hard to elicit
and they're hard to elicit because they
depend on on combinatorial properties of
the donor kidney of the of the donor so
today we have gotten it up to about 50%
and we do we make match offers much more
quickly so that we also get IV offers
result in transplants so no so this is
three offers so I'm just counting in the
whole thing so we get about 50% which
means that you know all three of these
would be would fail it now but instead
of but fewer of them family one thing
that's going on is we do more chains
notice that when a cycle fails
everything fails if I propose to you a
chain of length 7 and surgeon the
surgeon for surgery for rejects it we
still have a three surgery chain and we
might be able to repair it someone else
might take that kidney okay so so what
would we think a lot of a lot of these
rejections are what are called medical
reasons so they're the kidney is
compatible it's not a mistake to think
it's compatible it passes what's called
the positive cross match test but the
surgeon doesn't want it so what we
started to do is what we tried to do but
failed is we tried pushing the
compatibility graph to the surgeons and
saying to them look at this graph look
at all the kidneys that could come to
your patients these are the ones we
think are compatible if some of them are
going to be unacceptable to you please
tell us now we will delete those edges
from the graph and then we won't have to
do make so many offers to get to get
some transplants turns out you just
couldn't get surgeons to do that loosely
speaking the problem was we were showing
them many kidneys that they would never
get offered and it takes some work to
decide whether you would take a kidney
or not and it was too much work they're
busy they basically didn't respond so
what we then started to do and continue
to do is we offered them a threshold
language we said for your patients at
this time tell us what's the oldest
donor you would accept a kidney from
what's the highest body mass index how
heavy can he be how high blood pressure
can the donor have give us some
thresholds like that
now that
helps a lot but but we still get lots of
medical rejections because if you're my
surgeon you would like to be offered
many kidneys on my behalf so that you
can look at them and maybe one will be
good for me and you would like to take
it so you you put a pretty high age as
your maximum age you put a pretty high
weight as your maximum weight you put a
pretty high blood pressure as your
maximum blood pressure so then we show
you a kidney that meets all your
thresholds and you reject it and what's
going on well when you said you would
take a kidney from a 55 year old man you
were thinking of a 55 year old former
Olympic athlete in perfect health when
when you said you would take a kidney
from someone who is you know somewhat
overweight you were thinking of someone
who was 25 years old and so forth so
when we show you a kidney from a you
know a 55 year old man who's somewhat
overweight and has marginally high blood
pressure you look at your patient then
you say my patient is doing pretty well
today we don't need to take this kidney
now let's wait so we still were getting
lots of rejections what we've started to
do is we run when you run one of these
optimizations whatever it is you're
optimizing it's not always just number
of transplants you get multiple optimal
solutions and one of the reasons you get
multiple optimal solutions you could
already see this is remember there's
there's always type blood type o
patients going to be left over so
there's always a choice when you're
allocating a blood type O kidney about
to whom it will go so you can get
multiple optimal solutions and that now
we can show we can publish the day ahead
to to the transplant centers we can say
here are several kidneys that could be
offered to you at the next match
tomorrow if there anything you wouldn't
take let us know now and these are
typically kidneys that will go to
different patients in your new
transplant center so there are in deep
incentive issues with you trying to just
take the best ones but if there are some
you won't take you tell us and that's
that's helped and that's one of the
reasons why we're now at 50% and of
course the rate of rejection isn't the
important thing what's important is how
many transplants you get so we're also
react amaizing more quickly when people
say no we well one of the big exchanges
immediately cancels everything it says
you know we sent out a match this
morning not all parts of it were
accepted so forget it here's a new
optimization other programs depending
how they work some parts may go ahead
while other parts get reoptimize so
that's that's where we are now in
thinking about the incentives eliciting
information and the kind of algorithms
and matches that we'll do I better stop
here not the long chains right good
question so Steve is a eminent economist
and so maybe what he's worried about is
how come people who are left hanging at
the end of a chain your sister got a
kidney yesterday and you're supposed to
continue the chain tomorrow how reliable
is that turns out we have about a two
percent renege rate so that's a
complicated thing but it's well worth it
that's why you know we still get five
transplants per it was a long time
convincing people to do it the in New
England we couldn't get it to go ahead
but but my Greece at the Alliance
repaired donation did the first
non-simultaneous chain people are pretty
come first of all people are nicer than
we sometimes give them credit for so if
your sister got a kidney yesterday you
might feel like tomorrow you should go
ahead and give the kidney you would
promise but also think about think about
last Thanksgiving when your sister came
home and announced that you needed a
kidney and you stepped forward and said
that you loved her and would give her a
kidney and you turned out to be
incompatible but but but you went
through kidney exchange with her when
you guys go to Thanksgiving this month
later your everyone in your family is
going to tell that story it's gonna be a
great story it would be a harder story
to tell if you had not gone ahead and
given your kidney
so so people are complex in lots of ways
it turns out when you have to nominate
we have to be nominated to be one of the
parts of the chain that will be delayed
and have to wait the nurse social
workers have to like you
they don't nominate everyone so when we
do these non-simultaneous change there
were little simultaneous bursts of three
transplants typically and then a delay
and some nurse social worker has to say
he's committed he'll do it before you
get nominated for being part of the
delay so we don't do it with the cycles
and part of the reason is supposing you
and your sister are supposed to exchange
a kidney with me and my brother and we
decide to do it non simultaneously and
on day one you give us a kidney and on
day two for whatever reason we fail to
give you a kidney it could be moral
turpitude but it could also be that
something bad happens to the donor in
between or something like that well not
only it's not just disappointing it's
really tragic you guys have given a
kidney and got nothing in return and
next week when we run another kidney
exchange you won't be able to
participate because you don't have a
kidney anymore so we never let that
happen but in a non simultaneous chain
we organized them so that the pair's
always get a kidney before they give one
so if the if if the link breaks which it
sometimes does that's disappointing but
tomorrow when we run another kidney
exchange we'll we'll look for a kidney
for you
oh well there's yes well there's this
Methodist Hospital in San Antonio
they're one of my favorite hospitals the
surgeon there is named Adam Bingaman and
he runs a very successful one hospital
exchange and and a big part of his
success is he enrolls compatible pairs
so he loves lots of easy to match
players including compatible pairs so
supposing supposing I needed a kidney
the people who love me enough to give me
a kidney
are mostly about my age so there's my
wife and my brother and my wife's
brother and you know my brother-in-law's
kidney would would save my life but what
what he would say to me if we came to
his hospital is he'd say you know there
might be some people you could help and
in return
you could get a better kidney than your
brother-in-law's kidney and so if one of
the young people here you know needed a
kidney and has a donor who's an Olympic
athlete and in great health but who
can't give her a kidney my
brother-in-law's kidney would save her
life and the Olympic athlete 25 year old
Olympic atheletes kidney would be better
for me by and large what makes a kidney
good for you is its nephron mass sort of
how big and how young it is so and
having us there you know remember that
graph that had low sense as I said I
think it's a lot of low sensitize easy
to match pairs and that helps him do
chains and exchanges so we'd like to see
more of that one reason we don't is
because I haven't talked to you at all
about the financial engineering that's
going on here right now when I showed
you those first pictures donors traveled
but that doesn't happen very much
anymore now it's mostly that kidneys get
shipped and that means that hospitals
ship each other kidneys and then have to
try to recover the cost for their
nephrectomies which can be very
different hospitals in the United States
which I've had some indirect dealings
have nephrectomy costs going anywhere
from twenty-five thousand dollars to a
hundred and five thousand dollars so if
we send you a kidney and say and please
send us twenty five thousand dollars of
course we're not happy when you say sure
here's a kidney and and please send us a
hundred thousand dollars so one of the
so there are so there are lots of
reasons why hospitals like to to put
compatible pairs together because
they're paid simply
from the insurance of the patient or for
Medicare whereas everything else
involves financial negotiations one of
the big advances in kidney exchange
that's underway now is what is
developing what's called a standard
acquisition charge for this this is
something that like recent and a number
of colleagues are are doing and it's
looking like we can simplify the
financial flows and that that might also
make it easier so remember I showed you
two lists of papers one in economics
journals and one in in surgery journals
the surgery journals like simulations
with clinical data they don't like
random graphs but to understand what
we're looking for we like Whitney are we
the analytical types like random graphs
but we have trouble too for those of you
who like random graphs let me suggest
some some help we could use when you're
dealing with or any kind of random
graphs the big feature of the graph is
how does the probability of two nodes
being matched evolve as the size of the
graph increases and if it's over a
certain limit log n over n you're going
to get these very densely connected
graphs well as a as a physical fact the
chance that you can take my kidney
doesn't depend on how many people are in
the room so it would be very tempting to
model that as a constant and then of
course as the room gets big we have a
densely connected graph and we don't
need long chains but we do need long
chains and we are seeing sparse graphs
so you can look at order for any kind of
random graphs and lower the probability
of connection which is an unrealistic
assumption but which allows you to get
limit theorems about sparse graphs so if
you say you know that you'll have a
constant degree as the graph gets large
for instance you get things that look
very much like the graphs that we see
but that's not a great way to study them
because because it's a limit we're
looking at finite graphs we really need
better tools to study sparse graphs so
so we don't use random graphs in
deciding on matching we always have
particular patients we have particular
graph
for a random to try to understand their
general properties we would be glad to
have some random graph tools that are
more up to date than the
nineteen-fifties ones of Russia and
rainy yes questions it's a little bit
troubling I guess because it involves
everything here involves people's lives
but have you ever considered situations
where for example a very rare donor
shows up and you'd like to delay using
him in a chain because later he might
save many more lives he does know I mean
rare and not so we're so owed owners
have more prospects there's also what
makes you a powerful donor is so that
the immune the the people with high pra
the people who are who are really highly
sensitized can hardly take anyone's
kidney they have antibodies that target
these six locations on your chromosome
what makes you what can make you a
powerful donor you get in in the six
locations you get three proteins from
your mom and three from your dad and
each of them is a target for my
antibodies what makes you a powerful
donor is that you should be homozygous
in rare HLAs you should have some of the
six should be the same so that there's
fewer targets and they should be rare
HLAs the the kind of antibodies I have I
get antibodies from having had blood
transplant blood transfusions things
like that and if you have rare HLA is
then the chance that I have antibodies
to yours are rare so indeed there are
powerful donors on the other hand the
donors on their kidney and they come to
us if they're non directed we have some
chance of being able to postpone them if
they're directed it's it's a much
trickier question because of course
there's our patient that they have in
mind but we can but but that's one of
the reasons why it's a shame when
hospitals withhold they're easy to match
pairs because sometimes if we could see
those in the in the large compatibility
graph we could make much better use of
one the question of delay of how often
to do exchanges and of how to end the
end the the current exchange that is
you're going to deplete your current
pool and then it's going to have some
continuation value as you continue
those are all open to question so annum
Gary Hill who once the most prolific of
these National Kidney Registry he wants
you to say yes or no in a day and he
harasses you if you take a whole day I
mean he he expects fast answers alliance
prepared donation gives people a little
more time as a little slower I think you
know gives people still more time and is
still slower and this interacts with how
far along other things get so so the APD
the and K are they used to have everyone
did their own blood tests and
transferred blood so you would only
slowly find out that some exchanges
couldn't go through during which
preparations had gone ahead for other
exchanges so that involves you with a
different kind of optimization because
you're getting you're not in fact
optimizing it against your original pool
because some things go ahead and then
you have to be optimized with what's
left compared to if you get really fast
answers you can say everybody forget
what we said this morning that turned
out not to work we're going to
reoptimize you know with our with our
same compatibility pool so how fast you
can get answers does partly influenced
how many how many transplants you can do
yes so with the 15 years the last 15
years what stuff performance is
increasing the number of transplants
let's say so we're still small this is
just through 2013 but but Shane started
to become important around here and and
in these figures who are getting the
majority of the transplants their change
well so in 2013 we had 592 exchange that
was a total number so it's about 5,700
living donor transplants about 10% of
which were through exchange and it's
growing around the world but slowly
mostly in the developed world one of the
ways we would like to grow it is when
you look worldwide what you see I mean
here's the United States we have a bunch
of deceased donor and a bunch of living
donor transplant but there are places in
the world where there's hardly any and
we've started to explore the possibility
of bringing Filipino patients to the
United States and engaging them in
American Kidney exchange to be financed
by the savings that we get whenever you
transplant an American because either
Medicare Medicare saves around a quarter
of a million dollars in the first five
years after an American is transplanted
because dialysis is so much more
expensive than transplantation you're
the finances are very complicated
you guys all probably have find private
insurance unusually kidney disease has
the following story your private
insurance would only be responsible for
you for the first thirty three months
after which Medicare would take over
even if you're young you know kidney
disease is one of the injury pathways
into Medicare but they pay about twice
the rates of Medicare so private
insurance even though they only have you
for thirty three months can can save
even more money say it's about half a
million dollars every time an early
patient is transplanted so we could
start thinking about doing exchanges
with the developing world where where
one of the incompatibilities is that you
live in the Philippines where the
national health insurance sir national
health insurance only gets you 46
dialysis sessions which is nothing it
means that kidney disease as a death
sentence so but but there are people
with willing donors and of course lots
of questions would have to be answered
before you can do that in a regular sort
of way the first pair we organized
without solving the financial
engineering they were organized in a in
a philanthropy sort of way and the the
big challenge would be to figure out how
to move the savings to where the new
costs are right the the savings are in
Medicare and insurance and the new costs
are in surgical costs in the United
States and then post transplant care in
the home country so these guys took part
in a in an American chain and it you
know it can save a lot of money but but
so far we haven't figured out how to
move the money from where it's saved to
to to where it needs to be spent but I
think that this is an area and where we
might be able to grow kidney exchange
around the world